recibí este problema de un chico llamado
benito que no sé cuál sea su apellido ni
de dónde es donde vive pero el problema
es muy interesante y creo que no lo he
cubierto antes así que el problema que
medio sí leí bien es es el siguiente y
es resolver resolver la siguiente
ecuación que dice 3 seno cuadrado de x
es igual a 1 + coseno de x muy bien este
es el problema que hay que resolver y
pues al principio parece difícil
despejar verdad porque tenemos seno de x
coseno de x como que la única forma de
despejar es con por ejemplo arco coseno
de x sol o lo que es lo mismo el coseno
inverso de x pero si nos fijamos muy
bien podemos utilizar nuestras
identidades trigonométricas para
resolver este problema y por ejemplo
aquí tenemos un seno cuadrado de x y lo
que a mí se me ocurre es hacer lo
siguiente tomarnos bueno recordar que el
seno cuadrado de x si se lo sumamos al
coseno cuadrado de x
esto nos da igual a uno y eso viene de
la fórmula del círculo unitario verdad
el círculo unitario tiene coordenadas xy
pero satisfacen que x cuadrada massieu
cuadrada es igual a ere cuadrada pero
como es unitario el círculo r es uno
entonces esta fórmula viene de ahí lo
que podemos hacer es sustituirlo
directamente en esta ecuación de acá
arriba verdad entonces vamos a
sustituirlo tenemos voy a ponerlo así 3
por el seno cuadrado que el seno
cuadrado de aquí lo podemos bueno quizás
deberíamos despejar antes verdad porque
el seno cuadrado restamos de ambos lados
y coseno cuadrado de xy nos queda uno
menos coseno cuadrado de x muy bien y
ahora sí podemos sustituir si
sustituimos nos da tres veces el seno
cuadrado que es uno menos coseno
cuadrado de equis y esto debe ser igual
a lo que está del otro lado que es uno
más
coseno de ellos muy bien entonces
desarrollamos esto y deberíamos llegar
ya a otra expresión al menos en términos
de ccoo se nos iba a saber que queda
algo muy agradable muy bien entonces nos
queda 3 x
distribuimos y nos queda 3 por 1 es 3
menos tres coseno cuadrado de x esto es
igual a 1 + coseno de x y vamos a pasar
todo todo del lado derecho sumamos bueno
éste pasa del otro lado como positivo
entonces si pasamos todo el lado
izquierdo al lado derecho acá nos queda
a 0 y entonces tenemos 3 coseno cuadrado
de x verdad sumamos este de ambos lados
más coseno de x ahora voy a dejar este
ya llevamos este y este y ahora restó 3
de ambos lados y entonces me queda uno
menos 3 son menos 2
entonces hasta aquí ya tenemos una
ecuación de coseno de x igualada a cero
y es bastante interesante de esta
fórmula porque parece una ecuación
cuadrática
pero nuestra variable es coseno de x
verdad así que cómo resolvemos este
dilema simplemente hacemos este cambio
de variable vamos a hacer este cambio de
variable zeta ceta igual a coseno de x
ok si hacemos z igual a coseno de x
fijate muy bien tengo 3 tengo 3 que
multiplica se está cuadrada verdad
porque coseno de x ez entonces esto es
se está cuadrada y esto le sumamos le
sumamos le sumamos coseno de x que es
zeta
y luego restamos 2 restamos 2 y esto nos
debe dar igual a 0 y esto ya es una
ecuación cuadrática ya es una y es un
polinomio de grado 2 igualado a cero que
hay que resolver y si te acuerdas muy
bien de los vídeos de de fórmula
cuadrática y demás sabrás que las
soluciones menos b más menos la raíz
cuadrada de b cuadrada menos 4 a por c
sobre 2a sobre 2a
muy bien y quién va a ser b quién va a
ser a y quién va a ser se bueno este de
aquí es nuestro coeficiente a aquí
tenemos un 1 verdad ese 1 va a ser el
coeficiente b y menos 2 es el
coeficiente c
así que si sustituimos directamente qué
es lo que nos queda que zeta ceta esto
estos serían nuestros zetas z sería
igual a menos b que sería menos 1 más o
menos la raíz
be cuadrada que es 1 al cuadrado que es
1 - 4 que multiplica a que es 3 y luego
multiplicamos hace que es menos 2 pero
con este menos se hace más y simplemente
queda multiplicar por 2 y dividimos todo
entre 2 por a pero a estrés así que
dividimos todo sobre 6 muy bien entonces
ya casi llegamos ya casi tenemos todo
solo hay que desarrollar estas
operaciones y tendremos ya el resultado
verdad entonces esto será menos 1 más
menos la raíz de uno más cuatro por tres
son 12 por 2 son 24 y si le sumamos 1 es
la raíz de 25
todo eso dividido entre 6 ahora bien
esto es muy fácil verdad porque la raíz
de 25 la conocemos y eso es 5 entonces
tenemos menos 1 más o menos 5 sobre 6
así que ya podemos dar nuestra solución
vamos a tener dos soluciones unos para
el signo más y otra para el signo menos
entonces nuestra primera solución z1
será menos uno menos cinco que son menos
6 entre 6 que es menos 1 verdad y la
segunda solución es menos 15 que en este
caso son 4 entre 6 esos son dos tercios
verdad 4 entre 6 podemos dividir entre 2
arriba y abajo arriba nos daría 2 y
abajo nos daría 3 así que estas son
nuestras dos soluciones y tú podrás
pensar oye ya terminé el problema pero
hay que recordar que estos no eran lo
que queríamos encontrar porque z es el
coseno de x y yo quiero saber quién es
el coseno de x
así que ahora vamos a encontrarlo porque
si ahora tenemos que resolver lo
siguiente coseno de x igual a menos 1 o
puede ser coseno de x igual a dos
tercios 2
celsius muy bien
una es muy sencilla de resolver esta
primera coseno de x igual a menos 1 esto
nos dice que x es el arco coseno arco
coseno de menos uno o el coseno inverso
coseno a la menos uno muy bien entonces
la pregunta es para qué ángulo el coseno
dx es menos uno ok y si nos ponemos a
pensar realmente el ángulo es pi pi
verdades o 180 grados no a mí no me
gusta mucho usar grados es mejor usar
radiales así que x es igual a pi lo
mismo podemos preguntarnos para el
coseno de x igual a dos tercios esto
quiere decir que x es el arco coseno de
dos tercios y aquí si no esto no es
fácil no es trivial así que voy a sacar
mi calculadora
y podemos calcular 2 entre 3 y eso nos
da este numerito y sacamos coseno a la
menos uno de esos y es punto 84 10 6 en
fin vamos a dejarlo como punto 84 10
sale entonces x es igual a 0.84 1 así ya
vamos a dejarlo así verdad porque el
siguiente 0 así que
con esto ya hemos resuelto el problema x
speed o x es punto 841 ahora sólo vamos
a verificar que en realidad esta
ecuación se vale para x igual a ti
entonces 3 seno cuadrado de pi debería
ser igual a 1 más
el coseno de pi por un lado aquí tenemos
3 por seno de pi y lo elevamos al
cuadrado y del otro lado es uno más
el coseno de piqué es menos uno entonces
esto nos debe dar cero pero recordemos
que seno de pi es cero verdad en la
altura cuando uno tiene un ángulo de pi
verdad si uno tiene un ángulo de pi la
altura es cero
entonces esto vale cero y tenemos que
ser es igual a cero lo cual es bastante
cierto entonces con esto hemos terminado
el problema muchísimas gracias al buen
benito que nos envió este problema y
espero que te hayas divertido